what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are getting the conclusion of Titan Hulk
along with the origin of his character
which is really really cool so what this
does here is this initially picks up in
the mind of Bruce Banner with a little
bit of taunting from despair right
remember because of the fact that the
Titan Hulk basically originates in the
mind of banner when Doctor Strange got
involved his physical form is on his way
to Planet Hulk his spiritual form is in
the mind of banner right so he's just
there trying to get rid of the Titan
Hulk the best he can the problem is he
ends up encountering the fear Lord
despair but the thing about despair is
he's ridiculously op and in recent years
he was easily defeated by Doctor Strange
in a way that normally shouldn't have
been done but what despair does is he
actually gives us this kind of origin of
the Titan Hulk and telling us that what
had happened is that somewhere along the
line a green door manifested to despair
now anybody who's familiar with the Hulk
Mythos knows the significance of the
green door but that really comes from Al
Ewing's run so for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar you're with that
and again I'll have a link to the Hulk
playlist from Al Ewing down in the
comments section but when it came to the
Green Door the way this worked is that
in years past you just had people who
became different versions of the Hulk
Jennifer Walters became Incredible Hulk
doc Samson became dot green Bruce Banner
became the Incredible Hulk and so on and
so forth but what Al Ewing did is he
introduced the idea of the Green Door
that in effect whenever a person with
gamma radiation in their body and they
are a Hulk whenever they die a green
door opens and they can be reborn they
can basically come back to life it's a
roundabout way for immortality now we
ended up learning that the origin of the
Green Door actually came from the one
below all who was basically an answer to
the question what happens when the one
above all hulks out it was a pretty
insane Revelation at the end of that
story right like the god of the Marvel
Multiverse has a Hulk form and it's the
one below all it was pretty dope but
what despair says is that it was
presented with a kind of power or at
least a little semblance of Power by
this being now what despair says is that
this little nugget was given that comes
in the form of a red ball that it was
only a small form or a small fraction of
this being's power that it had an
astronomical amount of power now by all
standards of measurement it was the one
below all that gave this power to
Despair and anybody who knows anything
about our coverage about Ewing's hope
will tell you guys the one below all is
immensely powerful I mean there was
literally a point in the story where
alguing showed us what would happen in
the future when the one below all seized
control of the Hulk that it basically
destroys the whole Multiverse it's
reborn into the new Multiverse after
killing Franklin Richards and Galactus
and then destroys the next Multiverse
then it would just wipe these things out
continually until the end of time it was
a really awesome Revelation but because
of the power of the one below all even
just a fraction of it that despair was
overwhelmed by it right just like God
this is insane and in fact what was
instructed of Despair is that he was to
take this little fraction of what seems
to be the one below all's power and
place it inside the mind of banner and
that's where the Titan hold comes from
it's an external power source that is
slowly manifested and kind of gains
sentience over the years and that's why
we were never really given a definitive
explanation of where the Titan Hulk came
from it's not some alternate personality
of Bruce Banner it's not some long-lost
aspect of his anger and rage that he
never quite dealt with it's a foreign
body right it's like having some kind of
illness in his body a kind of cancer
that's just been growing over time and
manifests in the form of the Titan Hulk
now what this does here is it basically
leads to again this Revelation that
Stephen Strange's physical form is on
its way but with his spiritual form
basically overtaken by the combined
power of Despair as well as the Titan
Hulk Persona that what this does is it
actually leads to the body and the mind
of Stephen Strange merging their power
is completely reunified and then in turn
they're able to cast off the power of
Despair and effectively lock him away so
the only thing the only major issue that
we have left here is the Titan Hulk
itself right this physical manifestation
in the real world and this guy is laying
waste to everything thing right like
even Steven strange isn't fully sure
what to do because the level of power
that the Titan Hulk possesses here is
astronomical and if it really is a Hulk
powered by the one below all then there
really isn't anything that can be done
here but as this whole conflict is going
on monolith is doing her best to hold
off the power of the Titan Hulk but for
monolith's part one of the revelations
that comes out here is that in her fight
against Titan Hulk that where it
initially looked like she was beating on
him as best she could she was just kind
of doing what hulks do which is
physically attacking him blasting him
with her staff and magical energy and so
on what she's actually been doing this
whole time was siphoning off his power
was siphoning the power away from Titan
Hulk and it diminishes his capabilities
he's not nearly as capable as he was but
this is where the miscalculation of
monolith comes into play does she quite
literally siphons his power off and then
blasts him with it in the hopes it'll
destroy him and it sends him flying of
course not when that happens the other
hulks who were here who Titan Hulk just
absolutely demolished with the greatest
of ease that what happens is they
approach her and they basically tell her
like you've saved us everything's okay
and her response is no I haven't I
haven't saved anything like it was my
miscalculation I absorbed his energy and
I blasted him with his own energy hoping
it would destroy him and it didn't he's
absorbing it all right he's back to 100
again and he even has whatever energy I
had residually in my staff he's more
powerful than he was before and so
literally her response is we're
basically doomed there's no way our
world can be saved and even Steven
strange himself says that right he's
like with this level of power that
you're dealing with here there's no way
to save your world it's going to fall
and it's going to be destroyed and even
despair tells Stephen Strange that's the
goal here right the goal of Titan Hulk
is to siphon all the gamma radiation off
of this world in any other world that
exists in this universe and then destroy
the universe and move on to the next one
right so in a lot of ways what it looks
like Donnie Cates is doing is kind of
building off of what Al Ewing did sort
of giving us this depiction of the
events that took place between the time
when the one below all sees him control
of the Incredible Hulk and that
futuristic story where the one above all
have been traveling throughout the
Multiverse and just wiping out whole
universes over and over and over again
it's not explicitly told to us that's
what this is but it would be a cool
place to kind of fit it into so it's
awesome it's a really really cool
depiction on this thing but again one of
the things to understand and just
demonstrating the sheer level of power
that Titan Hulk has not even Steven
strange can stop this guy now you can
make transitive property arguments right
if we can cook the books and power
scaling and say well you know you know
maybe he's more powerful than dormammu
or something like that I don't
definitively know but what I will tell
you is a being as capable as Titan Hulk
seemingly imbued with the power of the
one below all is enough to go against
virtually anybody out there and it
doesn't matter who they are so no wonder
Stephen Strange can't beat this guy and
so what ends up happening here its
Banner starts talking to the Incredible
Hulk in his own mind because remember
the physical form of Hulk Banner
whatever you want to call it that's
Titan Hulk running around but Inside the
Mind banner and Hulk are kind of trapped
there and so what Banner starts to doing
is talking to the Hulk and saying you
have to do something we have to manifest
something has to happen here like if we
do nothing this entire world and all the
hulks on it will be completely
eradicated we'll be stuck here because
Steven strange will inevitably die and
then this Titan Hulk will literally
travel to our Homeworld to wipe out
everybody there and we'll be helpless to
do anything but just sit there and watch
it happen so if you care about nothing
Hulk then continue doing nothing but if
the lives of the people here matter and
if the lives of everybody at home
matters then do something step up and do
something and it's one of the coolest
things right because while that's going
on Titan Hulk is dominating everybody
right like Stephen Strange opens up a
portal to try to get the occupants of
this this whole planet to like a
different world Titan Hulk like
basically rips a hole through that
reality like tears a hole in reality and
then jumps through I mean it's crazy the
only time we've ever really seen a being
based on physical power do anything like
this was during the try on Juggernaut
story if you guys remember that when
Trion I was punching holes in reality it
was nuts right we covered that and in
fact we'll remaster it because it's just
a ridiculously amazing story but it was
just this op version of Juggernaut
punching holes in the universe it was
nuts it's not something that we see very
often and so what ends up happening is
that because of the pleading of banner
The Incredible Hulk finally steps up now
the irony of this is that when the Hulk
does step up the Titan Hulk Persona
basically tells him there's nothing I
need from you anymore right like I've
siphoned off everything I need I've got
your physical body nothing here matters
but something to understand here is that
the entire basis the entire foundation
of the Titan Hulk's existence is
predicated on the Hulk itself if the
Hulk isn't there the Titan Hulk's power
basically wanes because there's nothing
for that Persona to latch onto there's
nothing for it to become a part of right
like it's a really interesting Prospect
because what this does is it actually
leads to both banner and Hulk working
together and then punching a hole
through Titan Hulk and then leaving the
physical body right like actually
exiting out of the physical body when
that happens Hulk reverts back into
Banner's form and then in turn the
entire conflict ends right you literally
switch over to Banner in strange Academy
now here's the thing and this is
something that caught me off guard right
because it just suddenly ends and it's
just like what like it's just it's
suddenly over the reason why the story
ends this way is because Donnie Cates
the guy who's writing this is basically
taking a mental health break he's
walking away from the Incredible Hulk
series so it just ends suddenly like
without any wheel any any real thing the
only thing we're given here is some
measure of an epilogue where basically
doc Samson writes a letter to Bruce
Banner telling him like none of us blame
you for anything that's happened none of
this is your fault or anything like that
right like you should come back to
Planet Hulk sometime or Hulk Planet or
whatever and hang out right it'd be
really cool if we all hung out and did
God ball and all that kind of stuff
right as far as Titan Hulk's concerned
its power is basically non-existent
right like it's just not really there
anymore the force of power that was
being used to create it has effectively
left and of course we end up finding out
that source of power ends up
transitioning back to the person that
originally gave it who's basically the
leader who's imbued with the power of
the one below all from Al Ewing's run
right the leader of course being a
former Incredible Hulk villain but like
it just ends all of a sudden right it's
just like and we're done and and that's
basically it because Donnie case his
entire run was cut short because he was
focusing on a mental health break so a
very lackluster ending to what was
otherwise a phenomenal Incredible Hulk
story but thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
peace